[Music]  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  israel has been very careful in its  response  to the war in ukraine to avoid uh  alienating or angering russia the real  and most  pressing reason for israel's desire to  avoid antagonizing russia is because it  wants to maintain its own freedom of  action in syria  [Music]  the israeli position is very very slowly  moving slightly closer to ukraine  zelensky in particular has been really  outspoken in criticizing uh israel's  positions uh there's also been domestic  criticism within israel itself so i  think that's partly shifting the israeli  position and also the facts on the  ground  [Music]  you